[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue sur ce plateau vous
êtes le président de l'association 13
ans 15 fraternité vérité partie civile
au procès des responsables présumés des
attentats du 13 novembre 2015 à paris et
à saint denis vous avez perdu votre fils
thomas au bataclan ce procès qui a
commencé en septembre dernier est entrée
cette semaine dense est dans sa dernière
ligne droite avec le début des
plaidoiries des parties civiles inédite
ses plaidoiries tant sur le fond que sur
la forme on va y revenir ça fait près de
neuf mois maintenant il est temps que ce
procès se termine oui oui c'est vrai il
est temps que ce procès se termine mais
il était nécessaire
qu'il se déroule comme il s'est déroulé
c'est à dire avec une durée une durée
qui a été exceptionnelle et qui a été
encore allongée par les péripéties dues
à la crise sanitaire et aider c'est plus
de trois semaines ce sont plus de trois
semaines qui se sont ajoutés près de
quatre semaines aujourd'hui que chante
ajoutées au calendrier initial
c'était nécessaire la durée pour essayer
de comprendre je ne peux pas lire pour
comprendre car il est impossible de
comprendre pour essayer de comprendre
pour que tous les faits soient
remis boutabout que les pièces du puzzle
tente de trouver leur place et donc il
fallait que mais que cela ait lieu mais
il est temps que ça se termine je crois
que c'est la fin de ce procès c'est un
moment que vous attendez mais que vous
dites redouté pourquoi oui à plusieurs
égards
parce que parce que il me forme de
d'habitude c'est créer une forme
d'addiction s'est créé aussi temps pour
ceux qui comme c'est mon cas assiste
très régulièrement au procès pour
certains ces mêmes du quotidien que pour
ceux aussi qui l'écoutent par la
webradio un système qui a été mise en
place avec succès et qui était vraiment
qui correspond et répond à un vrai
besoin
donc il y aura il ya cette forme
d'habitude qui s'est créée ces sites
sept familles aussi qui s'est créé et
demain lorsque ça sera terminé c'est un
vide et qui va s'ouvrir
c'est un vide et puis on a aussi vu au
cours de cette de ce long procès les
témoignages des parties civiles c'était
un moment très important un moment de
grande humanité un moment de profonde
douleur aussi et finalement
à bien tout cela va nous manquer d'une
certaine manière vous dites de ces
témoignages qui ont eu encore qui ont
été faits ces jours derniers qu'ils ont
permis de faire revivre les morts oui
c'est vrai c'est c'est bien cela et si
ils ont fait revivre les les morts
c'était la volonté d'ailleurs que nous
avions essayé de la raison pour laquelle
nous avions tenté nous à fraternité n 13
ans 15 fraternité vérité de convaincre
nos adhérents qu'il était important de
témoigner parce que certains se posaient
la question de la terrre nos enfants que
nous avons perdus et le relais parents
tout sous ses proches qui sont décédés
ils ne sont plus là ils ne sont pas des
témoins donc quel est l'intérêt
finalement qu'il le soit représentée au
procès bien l'intéressé qu'il justement
qu'il soit incarné que l'on puisse dire
que qu'ils n'étaient pas des anonymes
qu'ils étaient bien des personnes qui
existaient qui avait un avenir devant
elle il était important qu'elle soit
présente au procès
arthur des nouveaux qui est président
d'une autre association de victimes qui
du 13 novembre disait sur ce plateau il
ya quelques semaines que ces débats que
ces témoignages avaient aussi permis une
forme de
réappropriation quelque chose de l'ordre
du rejet de la passivité auquel le
terrorisme vous assigne à ce que vous
partagez satigny moi je pars je partage
tout à fait d'ailleurs je partage
beaucoup des points de vue d'arthur des
nouveaux et les deux associations lfp
est 13 ans 15 sont très souvent
solidaires et unis dans leur choix même
si quelquefois des avis peuvent diverger
sur certains points en tout cas oui ce
procès c'était c'est une réappropriation
on l'a vu allons nous avons parlé
deux de ceux qui comme c'est le cas de
thomas monfils ont perdu la vie mais il
y a ceux aussi qui ont survécu ceux qui
étaient présents sur les terrasses ou à
saint denis au bataclan et qui ont
souffert et qui nous nous ont ici nous
livrer leur douleur mais qui ont pu
aussi se réapproprier les lieux les
moments c'est la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs elle l' effort paris sort
particulier avait souhaité que des
images et des sons soient projetés nous
avions un avis j'avais personnellement
un avis différent
cet avis il avait d'ailleurs été ensuite
soumis en conseil d'administration
discuter et finalement nous nous étions
rendus aux 6 à 7 à cette idée que
c'était sans doute souhaité un essai
bande ont été à diffuser effectivement
qu'elle a été philippe dupeyron votre
cheminement personnel pendant ces mois
d'audience
est-ce que sur le fond du dossier vous
avez appris des choses combler des trous
du puzzle oui certainement en face je
combler des trous du puzzle je ne
faisais pas partie de ceux qui
attendaient beaucoup de ce procès je
faisais partie de ceux qui considéraient
que le procès devait avoir lieu parce
que c'est un moment où la justice de la
république passe et que c'était une
ponctuation nécessaire et évidemment
c'est aussi la justice il faut que des
peines ou est infligée assez à ceux qui
ont participé à ces actes selon le degré
de participation
mais j'ai évidemment beaucoup appris je
ne faisais pas non plus partie de ceux
qui s'étaient accrochés à analyser
moment par moments minute par minute la
progression des terroristes j'étais
d'une certaine manière j'avais pris une
certaine distance mais il était
nécessaire que cela ait lieu et moi j'ai
beaucoup appris bien sûr je sais c et
puis nous avons appris de la justice et
nous avons encore une fois surtout pris
une
immense et insondable leçon d'humanité
le procès doit se terminer le 24 juin
quant à moi si je me trompe le délai
d'appel lui court jusqu'au 8 juillet
vous attendiez avant de ce procès je
crois vous l'aviez dit notamment sur ce
plateau de la dignité de l'exemplarité
de la justice mais pas qu'eux aussi
j'imagine du côté des parties civiles de
leurs représentants est ce qu'elles ont
été au rendez vous
alors ne le sait bien s'ils n'ont pas le
24 mai le 29 juin avec une semaine à
cause du dernier rebondissement de
carcasse pour le coc vide
louis la dignité la dignité
incontestablement elle a été présente
tout au long du procès elle est encore
aujourd'hui avec les plaidoiries des
avocats des parties civiles qui se sont
pour un nombre important d'entre eux
réunis dans une forme de collectif avec
justement cette volonté de ne pas se
répéter de ne pas faire redondance de ne
pas laisser trop libre cours aux ego où
les égos d'un avocat c'est finalement sa
vie c'est normal mais et donc il y a eu
cette volonté de se regrouper
encore une fois pour une majorité
d'entre eux ou en grand nombre il y aura
des plaidoiries les plaidoiries
individuelles de ceux qui ne sont pas
associés mais la dignité oui elle a été
à longueur de temps présente aussi par
la main d'un président jean louis périès
qui a toujours été ferme à mais avec
aussi une grande capacité d écoute de
lui et de tous les membres de la cour
les des assesseurs donc une une très
grande humanité grande écoute et
beaucoup de dignité encore une fois la
dignité des des parties civiles des
victimes qui sait s'exprimer dans la
douleur
vous avez désigné philippe dupeyron avec
plusieurs autres ong dont human rights
watch il ya quelques jours un texte
appelant au rapatriement des enfants de
djihadiste français et de leur mère qui
sont en ce moment on détenus dans des
camps du nord-est syrien avant que vous
expliquer pourquoi et pourquoi vous
pensez que c'est important que vous le
fassiez je voudrais qu'on écoute un
enregistrement qui a été fait
précisément dans le camp de roche il ya
quelques jours paraît human rights watch
en écoute vous voudriez aller où est ce
que vous voudrez guérir les enfants sous
pas
si
vous êtes française réunion accusant 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 enfants français asie c
est toi aussi madame
pourquoi philippe dupeyron il ne faut
pas laisser ses enfants et leur mère en
syrie
et bien au nom du droit les de l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant c'est la première
des raisons est c'est parce que pour des
raisons purement humanitaires et parce
que ces enfants là sont des victimes
réellement ce sont des victimes et ils
sont actuellement
détenues ou retenus en tout cas dans des
conditions totalement
inhumaine désastreuse de de dénutrition
de manque de soins d'absence totale de
d'éducation et enfin de choix éducatifs
et donc ils ce sont des enfants français
des ressortissants français et ils sont
victimes des erreurs de leur mère et
d'une certaine manière est la france au
lieu de se comporter en état qui fait
valoir le droit et qui donc doit
impliquer des mesures de justice aux
parents à leur mère qu'ils doivent être
rapatriées mise sous main de justice et
donc traduite ensuite devant les cours
d'assises spécialement constituée et les
enfants rapatriés et bien nous nous
comportons finalement d'une certaine
manière en appliquant la vengeance nous
ils ont des comportements des mères en
infligeant ces traitements aux enfants
le fait que vous association de victimes
du 13 novembre 2015 signé bien sûr ce
communiqué une charge symbolique majeure
oui et c'est tout à fait conscient de
cette charge que nous nous sommes
associés à ce mouvement pourquoi parce
que fraternité et vérité l'association
que dont je suis le président la
fraternité le premier des piliers qui
constituent cette association c'est la
main tendue c'est l'humanisme c'est
l'humanitaire et le second la seconde
raison pour laquelle nous sommes
associés nous nous associons volontiers
à cette action c'est que dans lé but de
notre association il y à la prévention
toute action tendant à la prévention de
la radicalisation et nous considérons
que le rapatriement de ses enfants c'est
une mesure de prévention de la
radicalisation
car en fait les laisser dans cette
situation là c'est les c'est se rendre
chez type de nourrir de leur part une
rancoeur à l'encontre d'un état dont ils
sont les ressortissants et qui n'auront
qui n'aura rien fait pour les sortir de
cette ce marasme dans lequel ils sont et
par conséquent c'est nourrir une
rancoeur qui peut se retourner contre
nous ça a été aussi l'avis de monsieur
deux pas le coordonnateur des juges
d'instruction du partic parquet national
anti terroriste qu'il considère que
c'est une mesure de sécurité la france
n'a pas à la différence d'autres pays
des politiques systématiques globale en
la matière très peu d'enfants et de
mères a fortiori ont été rapatriés ou en
tout cas ramené en france jusqu'ici
comment vous l'expliquez vous et comment
expliquez vous que le sort de ces
enfants ne suscite pas des mois si
important c'est pas le premier appel en
la matière et bien effectivement on ne
peut que s'en étonner on ne peut que le
regretter
et très amèrement parce que là au cas
particulier la france n'est pas ne met
pas du tout en accord ses paroles et ses
actes nous sommes effectivement très
prompts à condamner chez les autres des
comportements in humanitaire ou en tout
cas où les droits de l'homme ne sont pas
respectés
or ici nous nous comportons de cette
manière là pourquoi aussi il n'ya pas de
plus de réactions parce que j'oserais
dire que c'est la réponse à la rue on
laisse effectivement ce sont en condamne
ces enfants que mon condamne les maires
en dix ans après tous les maires on vous
lit dit on voulu y aller et bien qu'elle
y reste sans se préoccuper effectivement
des droits et de l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant donc il y a là une absence de
volonté politique qui me paraît vraiment
devoir être condamnée fermement pas de
réponse jusqu'ici aucune réponse
quelques mots enfin pour finir pour
revenir au procès pour reparler à
nouveau d'arthur des nouveaux son
association va être dissoute après le
procès car il disait ne pas vouloir être
une victime à vis moi je vous vois
froncer des sourcils en tout cas c'était
l'engagement qu'il avait pris il ya
quelques mois est ce que vous aussi vous
aspirez en deux mots à une forme de
repos après alors ni deux de deux
réponses en ce qui me concerne
personnellement j'aspire effectivement
une forme de repos aussi la raison pour
laquelle comme je l'avais annoncé depuis
longtemps des daims ma nomination mon
élection par dont cette fonction je
quitterai ma fonction de président à la
fin du procès c'est ce que j'avais
décidé je j'entends là effectivement
donner un peu de repos par contre
l'association elle
continuera continuera ses missions et en
particulier sa presse l'une de ses
missions
qui est celle de la perpétuation de la
mémoire est par ailleurs
demain nous l'avons dit va s'ouvrir un
grand vide et les associations doivent
être là pour aider les adhérents les
victimes à faire face à l'après procès
mais en tout cas si je français les
sourcils parce que je pense que la
dissolution de l'autre de lfp on en
reparlera les concerts merci beaucoup en
tout cas un fil de fer on est revenu ce
matin sur le plateau de paris direct
juste après la pause merci vous